the future of Life award goes to people
who played some pivotal role in Saving
All of humanity and most people don't
even know it if this movie was just a
movie and people saw it and went about
their way you wouldn't be recognized 40
years later is how did this end up
mattering geopolitically afterwards
Ronald Reagan as I said came to power
believing in a winnable nuclear war he
wound up changing his mind after he saw
the film yes Edmund Mars who was in The
White House who was his official
biographer he said the only time he ever
saw Reagan lose it was after he saw the
movie wow and Reagan went to Reg evic to
meet with gorbachov the treaty that
resulted between Reagan and gorbachov in
Iceland was the only treaty that ever
resulted in the physical
dismantling of nuclear weapons